the key to burning an ex-wife effigy is
to dip it in paraffin wax
and then toss the flaming bottle of
isopropyl alcohol
from a safe distance do not stand too
close
when you light an ex-wife effigy
no i don't plan to buy anything here i
buy my burger ingredients at food and
stuff
a discount food outlet equidistant from
my home and my work
i came here for the same reason people
go to the zoo
look at that thing
nature is amazing
i love food and stuff it's where i buy
all of my food and most of my stuff
okay everyone shut up and look at me
welcome to visions of nature this room
has several paintings in it some are big
some are small
people did them and they are here now i
believe that after this is over they'll
be hung in government buildings why the
government is involved in an art show is
beyond me
i also think it's pointless for a human
to paint scenes of nature
when they can just go outside and stand
in it
anyway please do not misinterpret the
fact that i am talking right now as
genuine interest
in art and attempt to discuss it with me
further
end of speech
happy birthday ron
ann said you had a big party sombreros
karaoke i did that for anne
why would i throw ron swanson an ann
perkins party
what about the giant list of things
april was doing that was just a list of
ways to mess with you
she do them all she did indeed
so i have rented bridge on the river
kwai and the dirty dozen
artie from security is outside the door
so no one will bother you
and a cab will be here whenever you're
ready to take you home
thank you i won't publicly endorse a
product unless i use it exclusively and
i really believe in it
my only official recommendations are u.s
army issued mustache trimmers
morton salt and the c.r lawrence fine
two inch ax style scraper oscillating
knife blade
this is your lunch
now you should be able to do whatever
you want to with this right
if you want to eat all of it great if
you want to throw it away in the garbage
that's your prerogative but here i come
the government
and i get to take 40 of your lunch
and that lauren is how taxes work but
that's not
fair you're learning uh-oh
capital gains tax
there's a sign at ramps at park that
says do not drink the sprinkler water
so i made sun tea with it and now i have
an infection
sir sir are are
are you listening to me sir sir i'm
talking to you
sir sir are you aware
that there is waste in your water system
i think if you would know one thing
about me it would be that i prefer
laying wreaths to lighting torches
i have cried twice in my life once when
i was seven
and i was hit by a school bus and then
again
when i heard that little sebastian had
passed i have accrued 228 personal days
starting right now i'm using all of them
while i'm gone you're in charge
also i keep a sizable supply of ground
chuck in my desk
remove it or it will begin to smell
godspeed
okay so here's what's going on i didn't
know friday i'm supposed to announce
that i'm running for city council
and i haven't told ben yet i know i said
that we broke up but we couldn't we're
still dating but now i have to break up
with him for real but i don't want to
break up with him because he's so cute
he's so nice
if you're gonna stay here there are
three rules you need to follow
one no talk about tammy one two no talk
about ben
three no talk i didn't even ask you last
night what is going on
with tammy once you just violated rules
number one and three
you lose your coffee privileges
ron most of these aren't even receipts
this one says i bought supplies
2007. you won't find any bank statements
either
i've heavily invested in gold which i've
buried in several different locations
around pawnee
or have i usually i only read nautical
novels and my own personal manifestos
but i'm proud to make this exception
thank you ron when people get too chummy
with me
i like to call them by the wrong name to
let them know i don't really care about
them
that's a genius move thank you
you're welcome lester
thanks ron you're welcome steve
for the last three years i have served
as troop leader
of the pawnee rangers this is our
handbook
i wrote the whole thing myself on
principle i never say anything that
another person is obviously
trying to get me to say my first wedding
ceremony took two hours
because after the priest said repeat
after me
i fell silent
this forum like all public forums is a
waste of time thank you
swansons are you prepared for whatever
lies ahead
yes sir before we proceed do any of you
have any dietary restrictions
correct you do not first outing is right
now
i will be teaching you to dig a proper
trench
does that sound like something you want
to do yes sir
this will be no fun at all
in my experience wedding presents are
nothing more than kindling
on the divorce bonfire can you at least
tell me what you're doing
i'm a homeowner i would like to actually
learn something
yeah i'm tightening the valve stem into
the valve shank
i'm replacing the handle and then
tightening the set screw which will hold
it in place
no oh my god we made it work
it's a good feeling sense of
accomplishment and pride
damn it i just love it so much
are you okay great i'm gonna go around
this house and fix
everything i can find that needs fixing
you want to help
i really do good
that's next flutes are 80
apiece and recorders are 150. hey
they're beautiful would you take a check
you can cash it tomorrow sure
[Laughter]
what religion am i well i'm a practicing
none of your
business ron you want to join us look
i'll let you be america and teach kids
that not only is government good but
that there should be a worldwide
super government i'd rather sand down my
toenails
every three weeks i have to sand down my
toenails
they're too strong for clippers to this
day
some feminists have even condemned
marriage
as a glorified form of slavery amen
there are these things called cookies
where like if you go to a site and buy
something it'll remember you
and then create ads for other stuff you
might want to buy so it learns
information about me seems like an
invasion of privacy
dude if you think that's bad go to
google earth and type in your address
every year i give leslie the same
present i give everyone
a crisp 20 bill and every year she gets
me
something thoughtful and personal it
makes me furious
this year she outdid herself
she had it installed over the weekend
so so beautiful
i don't want to paint with a broad brush
here but every single contractor in the
world
is a miserable incompetent thief
thanks ron swanson just the man i wanted
to see
i'm going to be going to a seminar on
the art of the japanese tea ceremony
or chicago at the pawnee community
college and i thought you might like to
come with me
why and who's this this is a
great friend of mine he is a fellow who
works in the building
and he is named kyle hey
ron thanks for coming man of course this
bowling alley has my favorite restaurant
in pawnee
really you're not scared to eat here
when i eat it is the food that is scary
you